welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some brilliant news to kick-start 2020
if you're a Marvel fan
a new report has just dropped from MCU
cosmic that says that Marvel Studios are
now moving forward and developing
projects around Netflix's defenders
characters
I'll leave the article in the
description below if you want to check
it out as this new story is really
starting to pick up steam now before we
get into the video though make sure you
subscribe to the channel for daily
breakdowns like this and to keep up to
date with the story as it unfolds anyway
thanks for clicking this Happy New Year
and now let's get into the video so one
by one it looked like the Netflix
characters had been dusted by Thanos
with each one of their shows being
canceled by the streaming service this
caused a massive massive backlash on the
internet with a lot of fans including
myself being angered by the fact that
that favorite shows would no longer be
airing to make matters worse we will
also inform that there was a stipulation
in the contract that stated that Marvel
would have to wait up to two years after
the shows were taken off air before they
could begin using the characters in our
own universe to simplify this all this
means that daredevil which was canceled
in 2018 would not be able to be used by
Marvel Studios until the end of 2020
however according to the new report this
has changed recently this apparently
comes from a quote unquote rock-solid
source at Marvel Studios who says that
the company are already well on their
way to utilizing the characters and
upcoming films and TV projects it has
been rumored for a while that daredevil
and Co will be making their way to Hulu
and that the devil of Hell's Kitchen may
even be appearing in the upcoming
spider-man 3 movie as Peter Parker's
defense attorney this seems like a dream
come true and many fans including myself
have been agonizing over seeing the
characters from the defenders universe
have brought across the big screen if
you like me then chances are that you
were gutted when they canceled the shows
however this is some brilliant news for
fans and I have to say that this and the
Hulk rumors have really made my week in
case you don't know it was also rumored
that the rights of the Hulk have gone
Marvel Studios so they can now begin
using the character in solo films sent
it around him so yeah good news across
the board now the report does go on to
say that the source cannot say for deaf
now whether we will be seeing a return
of the cast this is all going to be down
to contractual obligations and so on
though the characters themselves will be
free to use the exact same cast may not
be returning and Marvel will have to
work with the actors directly to
negotiate whether they'll be coming back
or not personally I think they will but
you don't know if actors have agreed to
other projects and so on
especially because in their eyes they
probably weren't coming back it's all
kind of up in the air at the moment but
personally I still think it's great that
Marvel will now have free rein over how
they're used and which movies that
they'll appear in this means that the
Punisher could be seen hunting after
spider-man in a film blade and daredevil
could team up Jessica Jones could fight
she-hulk Luke Cage in the Hulk could
become best friends and so on and so
forth the possibilities are endless and
it's such a good way to start the air
though we don't know if the two year
grace period changed it is possible that
Netflix decided to allow Marvel to have
access earlier and if this report turns
out to be true we may be seeing a return
of the characters a lot sooner than you
think
now obviously I loved you your thoughts
on this news and if you're excited to
see the characters return coming below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the rumored JJ Abrams rise
of Skywalker cut which you'll be linked
at the end we go over everything that
you need to know about it and why Disney
decided to cut so much so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come chat
to me after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which should be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of last
year and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
news in the comments section below the
one that's gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January in the subtle be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize
so best
like to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you